well we're bringing you some breaking
news now on that uh
our number of which we so often talk
about that is the infection rate well
the uk's
our number is now estimated to be
between 0.7
and 0.9 that means it's fallen slightly
from where it was last week
where it was between point seven and one
well uh let's tarry not let's get some
more analysis
on the latest figures from professor
roland cowell an epidemiologist
at the university of edinburgh a very
good afternoon
to you this feels like a significant
moment with the r number
back below one absolutely and
importantly is
not just it's below one but it appears
to be below one
pretty much everywhere where in the uk
which means that
as far as we can tell there are no
problem areas
yeah it's interesting isn't it as well
when you marry that up with the ons
data which suggests a pretty dramatic
drop in
infection levels again around around the
country
absolutely and it's really good that you
mention it because what it's telling us
is that all the various measures we have
at the moment
are heading in the right direction we
still have to be careful because
infection numbers are still
relatively high icu occupancy is still
relatively high
but we're on the right course for the
moment